[Music]
let's talk about battleship director
peter berg okay
uh he is a terrific director and and i
would think one of the most challenging
things with the movie on this scale
these kind of special effects is he's
got to when you're shooting the scenes
you're not there with the real aliens
they add all of that later on no the
real aliens don't come down to shoot
with us right right yeah yeah they're so
difficult sometimes yeah well they've
got very powerful agents exactly it's
caa so you have
you you you have to shoot these scenes
but you have to look really frightened
how does a director like peterburg get
you into that state if you're i mean
what are you looking at first of all
just a green screen men in pajamas truly
they they wear these they are they the
guys who dress up like the aliens
they're wearing pajamas with polka dots
all over them and then later later
they'll go in and they'll make them look
like aliens but you're supposed to be
terrified of men in pajamas and you're
like [ __ ] that guy just ate like a you
know dozen donuts it's kind of funny
he's done he's like gray sweatpants he's
not scary at all right so peter berg one
day we're on set and he has this like
sort of god mic that you just sort of
hear reverberate through the mountains
as you're shooting it cause action from
somewhere i'm not quite sure where and
all of a sudden i'm supposed to be
terrified like really really scared in
this one scene and he calls action all
of a sudden i hear this machine gun come
out from behind the bushes like
that wasn't a good impersonation but you
know like a machine gun that sounded
like a little snake well give me give me
the
that's a snake going to sleep i'm
turning in yeah
but like you're chewing your scene in
your hair like
like that
yeah and it's my director just reigning
just taking this gun firing it off on
the set and i think they were blanks i
hope he was firing blanks but he fires
this gun off and i jumped out of my skin
on camera and he's like cut we got it
that's the response i wanted and that
that's basically how he gets a reaction
out of you
that's not acting that's just scaring
the crap
i don't even think the gun's legal yeah
exactly what kind of director is he in
this next scene i want it to look like
you've been shot in the arm so i'm going
to shoot you in the air
how strong are you yeah